the thing that people still don't get
with in person is that like you can
control every variable you control what
they saw before they walk in how the
parking lot looks what's on the door
when they walk in what's the temperature
of the room where are they seated are
they holding their phone are they not
holding their phone there's so much more
control you have over the in-person
sales setting that like you can just
stack the deck give them the illusion
that they have a choice about buying
because like fundamentally like they're
walking into your mousetrap and you have
done this a thousand times and this is
the first time they've ever done it like
one of the things we found with the gyms
you know those A-frames a lot of people
print those out and they just put a
banner on it printed from the flyer
store or whatever does it work almost at
all because everyone ignores them if
they're printed but if you have a
chalkboard version or a whiteboard
version then you just write the same
thing in handwriting everyone will ask
about it